that i think it was like five or six you
asked me to audition for another movie
you were doing with that
it was an audition it wasn't it was an
offer and i was a straight offering yeah
but
the dialogue was so broken the asian it
was so thick yes right yeah i just kind
of passed on it and i felt bad because
yes you know i mean i love him and i
want to work with him again yeah but i
just didn't feel it
who
who who got the job before we go into
that yeah that kind of hurt my butt a
little bit it did yeah
and i i felt that it did maybe how do
you you could have texted me
all right mm-hmm right let's get let's
go there let's go let's go let's go now
hold on yeah
obviously he wasn't with him
character defect 91a um no but the thing
is about the movie and it wasn't a great
movie and it didn't get theatrical
almost did we didn't and but now it's in
reruns all the time
it was called the hungover
games
and so it was
kind of almost like we're doing with
cern talk it was like the guys from the
hungover yeah i know what it was woke up
yeah yeah no and they were in
what's that place and uh yeah in the
hunger games yeah yeah they woke up
there yeah and aura
anyway so it was like a parody
your character
was
the ken john character what's his name
yeah yeah yeah hang over yeah you were
mr chow yeah but it was like super over
the top
bad
on purpose it was like an alternative
so it was like why is he going over the
top yeah you understand who got it
that fan
is that a bad word here
dad's just the sweetest guy the sweetest
guy in the world sweetest guy in the
whole world friendliest guy he's so
friendly yeah i think he won the thing
yeah he won the thing yeah um he won and
he was the nicest guy i haven't talked
to him in a while yeah i have no idea
your history i don't know mesa turned
from white to pink
robot went shut down mode
he went back farther in the closet
he came in he read a bunch of times
that's great
i have like
i like him
in fact we love him so we love him so
much is that we talk about him a lot
because he loves the show yes have we
met him on the show he will never do it
wow there's some kind of thing there's
nothing there is nothing really he'll
never do it i'm doing it does that
matter okay you had jordan do it
all right i don't all right there's
obviously a thing that just stops us all
right so i just want to
and i'm not making fun of anybody i'm
not this is not i'm i'm watching what
i'm saying i just [ __ ] took down true
tv i'm [ __ ] no you're not all right go
ahead i liked it okay
this is that
you and jordan
right
you guys are wearing they are in movies
and [ __ ]
that's it that's all i'm gonna say
i took i got that i'm point taken yeah
there's a lot of history there i don't
know i don't i sounds like you guys
there's no history fine no i love them
there's no history okay i was just i
just throwing out a fact and you know
what the way you cackled right he was in
my movie who was i mean went to write
the red box what did my movie where dad
was in it what the hell never a hunger
game yeah yeah i think it went to like i
didn't even because i saw
because i watch everything he's in
wow this is
i watch everything he's in and i have
seen his scenes in the hunger games i
didn't know it was that
wow
yeah did you like his scenes
i like him
so yeah everything he does
dude why don't you tell me all right all
right i don't know you probably talk
about it a lot in your pocket no no
that's fine was he one of the kims of
comedy no because he's not korean okay i
know that was really nice that was
racist well you're laughing
have you been never disappointed meeting
like an actor you worked with we're like
oh [ __ ] this guy's a dick
oh i mean it happened oh yeah i mean i
here's the one person that don't say i
still i'm gonna say that i'll give a
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] all right brook shield oh
yeah i think you've talked about this
yeah
oh
is that
i did a pilot call i don't think i
talked about on this podcast oh go ahead
i did a pilot called um new car smell
don't know what that is exactly
and it was i don't care brook shields
was a star
dave attel was in it and that wasn't it
okay
and i'm gonna just tell you what
happened
it's the most [ __ ] up show business
experience i've ever [ __ ] had in my
[ __ ] life and i'm also gonna [ __ ]
talk about the show runners because they
they're [ __ ] two brothers and they're
[ __ ]
okay names distractions i won't i won't
say
brother yeah what
why
i don't just brook shields is enough
no because they've all right just say
what they said first then we'll decide
all right so this is what happened okay
so i was on mad tv
and
fox calls me and says listen
we love you on mad but
we we want you to do this other show
like what is it it's called new car
smell it's got with brook shields
and but the problem is
is the showrunners don't want you
who are the show brothers
i knew one of them personally
because he was andrew dice clay's friend
okay
and i went to vegas with him once
okay
so i go but i know that person and
they're like yeah but they don't want
you in it they want getty wanna knobby
you know what that is no long talk
that that's his name was his name again
from sixteen candles that's his name
so i show up you know i mean and
they're like they don't say hi
i'm it's [ __ ] rob cullen i don't give
a [ __ ] i hate him yeah and his brother
and every day i show up
i get less and less
dialogue oh they're cutting your [ __ ]
out yeah they're cutting me as the days
go by
and this is like two a week and a half
almost two weeks i would show up
and
and you know who directed it david
swimmer who was the nicest guy
i could ever work with i mean he was
so apologetic to me
and he would look at me and go i'm so
sorry but they cut another scene or
whenever right and i tell david tell was
so nice because i knew dave i'd been on
tour with him
so you know i had allies there it's just
that they knew it was happening too oh
yeah i felt it okay and then by the time
we shot the show
i had one line and i i had i was like
the restaurant next door that they would
all go to you know what i mean this it's
about a car lot it's a car salesman
it's called new car smell
and check it out yeah if it's out there
and um that one line
and then i remember and then the whole
time i was working two weeks and my
scene is with brook shield she never
said hi to me any time of any rehearsal
or i would show up in the morning i
would say hi to her she wouldn't say hi
back
and it was just like she knew that they
didn't want me
right so she kind of just like said [ __ ]
this loser to you know what i mean and
not be nice and it's like
and so
that's what happened i'm going to say
this is that
you know
i
love getting one lobby right but
i think that i i'm better
yeah
i truly do
and um
they can go [ __ ] themselves
well the show didn't make it clearly it
didn't make it but she was so hot in
blue lagoon i know she was and i was a
fan of hers before but it's like nah
great eyebrows too yeah but she's like
because you know when i did when i did
when i did um our list on hbo
it was another night i was new i never
never took an acting class i didn't know
what i was doing
and still
under that pressure and other feeling
like you don't mean they're going to
fire me at any moment
sandra oh
was a [ __ ] princess
she introduced herself she gave me a hug
she was like you're doing great you know
i mean she gave me a lot of words of
advice
and that's all you want as a young guy
you know i mean when you're in the
business is somebody older person
to go hey i got you
you know i mean and it's like
i didn't get that from them
and then get that from her
and i feel like
that i should have got it
yeah because i'm bobby lee
and i say that i say no i say that no i
don't say that in an egotistical way but
i say that in the sense that like i
spent you know me eight years on a
sketch show i've done a bunch of movies
i paid my dues and i'm still in it and
i'm still doing it and it's like go [ __ ]
yourself mm-hmm
yeah you know for not supporting me
because i support everyone
you know i mean yeah it just got me so
angry just now there's just that rant oh
brook shield i don't like him
oh here you know who else was in it i
forgot his name he was so nice she
didn't age well either so god you know
hammered down on her a little bit thank
you god
the guy that was in it that lead the
lead it was brook shields i forgot his
name and i worked with him in another
movie he was super sweet maybe she was
going through postpartum depression
that's not what it was it was it was it
was obvious that those brothers didn't
want to head out from the end they had
it on me they wanted getting one up and
the network said no and it's like it's
fine yeah fine yeah that doesn't warrant
like the the the treatment that you got
though let's suppose the network chose
you remember rob pulling me aside it's
acting
you gotta learn how to act
like you gave me this acting the show
the showrunner yeah yeah
yeah he gave me this like you know what
i mean you're not just a community you
gotta act
you know what i mean
and it's like
bro number one it's like
go [ __ ] yourself so you're already
getting bad energy while you're yeah
it's like it's like what are you talking
about first of all you're doing a
three-camera sitcom
you know what i mean
the same it's a multiple called new car
smell yeah yeah
buy the title alone it was a multicam
yeah and he's telling you
it's a multicam yeah [ __ ] you talking
about yeah just read the lies of yellow
yeah i mean and it's like it's like you
know what i i i will
like when
i did that movie just for a couple weeks
i was only a couple scenes but greg
mottola was his director he did uh you
know he did um
um what's that uh movie with uh alien no
no he did paul but he also did um
that one with jonah hill and like micah
smells super bad super bad he directed
super bad right
so greg you know when he gives me a note
right i listened to him you respect it
because i respect the note
right and
you know he hired me and he's somebody
that i've heard of before
you mean and i've worked with before and
i trust you know i mean
his opinion
if he says hey slow that down i'll
[ __ ] do it if judd abatto gives me a
note i'm going to take it
all right
but don't give me a note right and be a
dick also on top of it
is all i'm saying yeah yeah i'm sorry
no don't be i just got really just angry
i really got angry
to respond to him yeah what's up with
your you can't text me
directly i had to go talk to emails nine
emails for you to come here wait durmer
had to contact you yeah
dude you don't text me back that's true
oh that's true that's true also you have
green bubbles i don't want to text you
that's true
you have green bubbles it's a great
bubble you don't need an iphone
iphone has made it so that where i
really don't want to text people with
green bubbles
wait wait so i should i have to get an
iphone everyone yeah yeah i think so
i'll buy you one no i have money i know
you do but one reason why no the reason
why i would definitely make me on a gift
to you yeah
the reason why i have a samsung is
because i'm trying to be korean loyal i
i get that right i do have no like
ethnic ties to [ __ ] no that's because
i'm just a weird little meat puppet from
yugoslavia slash los angeles slash like
yeah yeah i have nothing yeah i have no
ties to anything you're a viking yeah no
i'm not i wish yeah was that what viking
is the other side
i'd be way hotter i would have blonde
hair my skin would be glowing you would
see no pores
yeah i got pores dude i got big pores
you have big pores for an asian asians
yeah you also have like asians are not
supposed to get liver spots
i'm so i know they're freckles i mean
just giant freckles yeah but generally
you look really young though
fighting words
you look great sweetie look at me i'm
melting so you say this is what you say
you say this is what you say to your
boyfriend you say um
i have big pores on my face i've never
heard that insult i've never heard of
that yeah that's a new one if you told
asians aren't supposed to get liver
spots i mean freckles big freckles
you look great you look great though you
look like a break
aside from those two glaring
i mean discrepancies on your face
yeah that's [ __ ] [ __ ] ambition yeah
you're being a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm kidding i love you that's what we do
i like this
is that wrong it's bad are you mad
no shut up
but you know what you're right because
there have been incidences in my life
where i still think about me too there
was this guy named dan
who um i used to work for his dad was a
construction worker
and my job i was 21 years old and my job
was to go to like lumber yards and order
like
you know i mean wood and then i would
also get like
tools or you know and wrenches and
things that they needed right
and so i went to this one lumber yard
and there was two runners me and this
other white dude
and i had never gone to this lumber yard
before and the guy that
that worked there said to me oh you work
for dan i go yeah he goes
what happened to the other guy that
american looking guy
that's what he said and i just went oh
no he's you know not working over you're
like uh what he's not working right now
and then
i left
and that's been in my head
for [ __ ] 25 30 years how old was this
guy who said that 40 50. i don't know
white lumberjack guys as if white is the
only american i know but that's what he
said where's that american guy and i
wonder myself i don't even know
what i should have said i don't really
know what you mean by that statement
because i'm an american person and i'm
an american looking person but at the
time it was just like but he would have
said no you're a ching chong and then
you would have said then i would have
said you're right
because i was a little kid yeah yeah i
was little i had no money and i needed
this job and i didn't you know i had no
power
you know the american-looking guy yeah
that he said that
and then that one guy in nashville to
tell me to pull my pants off oh that's
the right thing you know i mean so
there's all it does affect you
you know and basically what it is is
that
just people just don't want to mind
their own [ __ ] business man
yeah i think that um you know they
always they always teach you when you
learn any type of martial arts that you
know because you are a weapon and you
know your own strengths
just walk away right
and sometimes that's really hard to do
but i think that is a good lesson to
carry over in life because even if you
tell even if steve let's say for
instance if i were in steve's situation
and i told that [ __ ] off like no [ __ ]
like i could say whatever the [ __ ] i
want like mind your own goddamn business
you know would would i really go home
and feel good about myself no and i've
had similar confrontations where i have
spoken up and said the right thing and
i'm like wow i [ __ ] nailed it i hit
the you know ball out of the [ __ ]
park and that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know got
what she deserved and i and i still went
home and felt ill so i think that it's a
lose-lose yeah it's a lose-loser i don't
know any way to
to win in that situation because you're
either you feel like a coward or you
feel like you you were too mean or you
don't you know it's
i don't know i i've been on both ends of
it and it it confrontations never make
me feel great well you know what i wish
this what could happen is and i think
i'm gonna do this the next time i
encounter a situation like this is i'm
gonna wait a beat
before i say something okay
so my initial responses and all these
situations have been like i'm sorry i
won't do it again like immediately
does this say pull my pants up hey dude
pull your pants up i'm sorry
okay that's how fast yeah so now to say
it dude pull your pants up
um no
i won't
because now i beat actually helps yeah
that three seconds you kind of gotta go
how can you live with this for because
that pulling the pants up thing i can't
live with it you really still think
about it i think about it every day but
aren't you possibly inviting even more
no because it was it was a big old white
dude wearing overalls who
i was in the south i was in nashville
tennessee not your territory and he was
basically saying
in my head hey you little minority yeah
yeah i mean i'm white i get to tell you
what to do that's how i perceived
it i don't like that he put his arm
around you yeah he put his arm on that
was the most effective charge
yeah like get your hands off me number
one oh that's condescending it's like
listen to your young book like i'm not
your young buck not your child yeah
don't you're not my parents yeah
uh oh i walked out of a mall in san
antonio with carlos mencia and i was
like [ __ ] that guy i was talking about
somebody
and then this this white man said
watch your language like in an
aggressive way and then carlos laughed
and then i didn't say anything all those
little things stay with me
welcome to the podcast and uh another
episode of tiger belly um i have to
admit
right now i think we did a gratitude um
podcast last week this is about rage i
don't know why but i am full of rage
right now
um last night my brother and i were
playing
video games ice destiny and i wanted to
gouge his [ __ ] eyes out
what did he do well he goes revive me
and i didn't know where he was
you know yeah like because there's three
guys attacking me i don't know where my
brother is and then we all died and then
my brother how come you didn't revive me
and i go well how come don't die then i
said that he realized and then for two
hours he could be saying don't die
you die all the time
you know you know and then
today we're at the verizon store kalila
and i uh and the guy was really cool his
name is nate really nice guy but they
know what he said what oh oh hot dog
oh oh hot dog yeah that was a character
i did on mad tv
bobby i hate i hate it he just yelled it
they didn't yell it but he said hey dude
remember oh hot dog or something hey do
you remember for a split second he could
have died
that's how much rage you have today yeah
jesus i had to hold back he's lucky he's
alive really nice guy though nate thank
you for your help today he helped us by
the way for three hours
i was there um at brookstone
looking at stuff and um
this mexican dude that worked i don't
know why i had somebody mexican
he goes hey man i really enjoy your
earlier work
jesus
and i go thank you and then i walked out
of brookstone and for the next nine
hours i thought about that
okay he didn't mention anything in mad
tv no it's just early work so that when
people say i enjoy your earlier work
they only care about mad what i did i'm
mad and that time period right
they don't say later work because the
[ __ ] i'm doing now
is obscure almost not me not about your
mainstream
it's not bad i guess the love is a cool
hip show
with a bunch of hipsters and it's good
good quality you know writing yeah
writing and stuff but
it's not mike and molly
you know got cancelled
when bobby and i were in kauai we went
to this ranch and we i had never ridden
a horse in my life i don't know if you
guys know this i thought you would have
in the philippines you guys i think i'm
meant to ride horses though i feel like
my next goal is
i connected with the animal we got along
and but before we did we before when we
first got to the ranch bobby was
bragging the whole time okay okay
all right are you gonna you all right
can i just say this though easy because
i have arguments with every point that
you're going to make yeah please have
the platform go ahead please have that
platform
you may have the platform go ahead so we
get to their ranch and they match you
with a horse according to your height
and weight and your personality
basically
how do they measure that i don't know
well
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] the way they
measure it's a gut feeling i guess it's
the vortex okay
so we
there were like 12 people in a group and
then everybody gets matched up with a
horse i get matched up with a really
sweet horse named dudley very calm
mellow bobby gets matched up with a
horse named sizzler
he's really like the
restaurant
no
it's his
behavior and they're like oh sizzler is
a character
yeah i was like and the lady was like i
think you guys will go
wow
and so i get on sizzler and so he's he's
he's laughing at me because he thinks
that i'm
nervous to be riding a horse for the
first time of course i am because this
is massive
you know beast between my legs
but
um we know as we are getting on our
horses he's like yeah i like he tells
the lady he's like yeah i've done this
like i've ridden a lot i went to
kentucky like he basically paints
himself a [ __ ] cowboy yeah yeah like
he's a [ __ ] wild wild west like he
barebacks horse like mustangs okay
basically but basically that's what he
said
but what i'm doing is a fact i have
written horses before i know but you
made it you were laughing you're trying
to humiliate me in front of everyone i
know but i just said i've ridden horses
before
i'm not a liar
i've never heard a horse before because
if you said that then they would give
you extra you know instructions sure i
don't want the extra instructions
yeah so we go across this like jurassic
park beautiful beautiful round imagine
unable to control sizzler
is stopping every two seconds to graze
and he's like stop it stop it
you're yelling oh my god you know how
like he's you know you're supposed to
hold the reins like this he's holding it
like this like he's [ __ ] i was like
has this guy ever ridden or [ __ ] hold
reigns before yeah and he's like stop it
sizzler and he cannot control his horse
oh can i just say this though the fact
that now can i defend not yet i'm not
done with the story
we finally get to the end of the spot
and i'm thinking i'm not sure if he's
ever ridden a horse before yeah and so
to make matters worse he's already kind
of frazzled because sizzler is like not
behaving at all right and it's making
him look bad as he's trying to dismount
the horse just decides [ __ ] it i'll
dismount him for him oh
and bobby just rolls off the [ __ ]
back of the horse and it's this loud
like
sun to the ground
i was
crying i was crying because all you see
was his little portly body just [ __ ]
just
like on the ground
oh my god it was so funny uh defense
uh
it's you know um
hey did you have sizzler
did you have a character horse i get on
sizzler
and guess what half his ear is missing
oh
really yeah you didn't know that half
his ear had been chewed off
right so i'm going there's something
wrong with this guy
right yeah and the reason why i was
holding the reins that way is because
the other way he was so strong that i
couldn't get him up i had and my hands
were hurting i had to do it that way
and yes i have a portly body and my legs
are short and
all right and my my left foot got stuck
in the stirrup
and when i was coming up it wouldn't uh
release my leg my foot from the story it
was stuck
so i ran i rolled off the [ __ ] thing
it hurt and this is so ungrateful like
we i did it
how am i ungrateful i wanted to
experience life with you and go horsey
back riding and do zip lining and you
make fun of me and you humiliate me
i the best like in my head forever and
blaze in my mind is bobby's little um
short legs like clacking on the horse's
body just to kind of get him going it
was just like
this is like the cutest thing he's like
come on sit come on come on wow click
click click
it was
a great trip that was great and then um
we went also one morning
and we basically took a boat ride around
the island yeah
and
laughing
it was just a bunch of kids vomiting
we went right after a storm yeah and
then i called that morning i was like
hey is there